salut vous l'avez compris dans le titre
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo un petit peu
ouf mais avant de lancer cette vidéo il
faut que je vous raconte la genèse en
fait un jour j'ai rencontré un mec qui
s'appelle michael et c'était un abonné
l'icône des choses et moi j'avais besoin
de faire une application pour mon
spectacle application qui s'appelle
fabien olicard on n'a pas trouvé plus
simple elle sert durant le spectacle
durant le spectacle les spectateurs ceux
qui sont venus me voir le savent on se
sert de ça ça s'appelle le vix bugeaud
d'ailleurs petite info si vous avez
l'application ne la désinstaller surtout
pas parce qu'au mois de juin il y aura
une mise à jour avec un cadeau pour vous
lis les lignes de code en fait c'est
matrix ce mec c'est neo
il le sait pas mais ces néo bref il m'a
proposé aujourd'hui de me montrer qu'ils
trouvaient un mot de passe plus
rapidement que mon en clair il peut
mentaliser un ordinateur il peut
mentaliser un mot de passe et moi j'ai
dit ok daffé mois voire génériques
[Musique]
mineo c'est lui qui est dans la matrice
taïga ça lui fait de l'arrêt s'écoule
alors si j'ai bien bien compris on est
en or die dans le fait sur mon imac sur
un ordi que jamais un ordi mais peu
importe leur dis absolument faux
complètement tu es capable de détourner
le mot de passe exactement la toi t'as
pas besoin de moins balisés quelqu'un
pour le trouver moi je devine pas moi je
alors je te propose que tu nous prouve
et après que tu nous l'expliquent ça
marche
je vais moi même maître un mot de passe
sur ta bécane ok et après tu essaies de
rentrée ok là où je tape le mot tu as ce
que je veux moi absolument que tu
regardes chez ta mère tu sais quoi
j'espère sincèrement que ta technique
est bonne parce que j'ai tapé n'importe
quoi donc je ne sais pas ce que j'ai mis
la balle donc ça c'est fait ça marche
maintenant je vais tourner la caméra à
partir de quand j'te de filmer faire est
ce que tu as besoin d'une zone secrète
d'absolument créé jouines je vais me
retirer et faire des manipulations again
et bien retire toi pendant ce temps là
je vais parler à personne contre je le
met un petit compteur juste la halle ici
par là autour de moi je m un conteur
quelque part et je vous dirais que
durant combien de temps il s'est retiré
comme si la si joliment dit si toi aussi
ce mot tâche ok tu peux mettre un
hashtag choqué et déçu dans l'espace
commentaire bon en tout cas je ne doute
pas qu'ils soient capables de le faire
par contre j'ai hâte de savoir comment
il va faire et si c'est facilement
faisable ou pas en fait parce que c'est
ça en fait avec les génies c'est à dire
que l'usam lui paraître simple et nous
on peut ne rien comprendre
mais je trouve ça dingue qu'il arrive à
passer le mot de passe de base sur les
sur les sur les ordis normaux les mac tu
as fini oui c'est vrai donc là on est
sur l'écran d'accueil
absolument vas-y top le mot de passe
senard date parce qu'il n'ya pas que
trois trucs mais mais qu'est ce que
c'est donc en fait ça avec un mot de
passe en trois caractères que tu as pu
rentrer absolument je peux le refaire
avec 12 tu veux je veux je veux le
revoir avec avec sept caractères c'est
ainsi qu'en fait c'est top littéralement
n'importe quoi là je sais pas btg c'est
moi aussi un beau nez je prends
abonnez-vous je rends et là t'as rien
débrancher la cie n'ont ils rien à
l'intérieur rien il est comme tout à
l'heure c'est le même mort dit t'as pas
installer un programme
t'as pas besoin d'être connecté à
internet parce que t'as pas mon mot de
passe wifi c'était un partage de
connexion non rien genre si tu es dans
un grand magasin atac carrefour je peux
faire la région avec tous les ordis et
les mac aussi et l'imac aussi va être
exactement ce à quoi donc en clair déjà
ce que tu es en train de me dire c'est
que le mot de passe de la page d'accueil
ça ne sert à rien a que dalle que ce
soit bien clair d'accord ok j'espère que
t'as rien à cacher par exemple sur ton
ordi non non bien sûr que non mais non
par contre je peux effacer de choses à
distance explication utiliser un outil
en fait qui est assez qui régulièrement
utilisé par les mecs qui ont des petits
magasins des petits magasins
d'informatique et en fait c'est tout
simplement sur une clé usb que je les
miss 1 c'est un petit logiciel en fait
alors c'est par le cheik classique dans
le sens où il va pas s'exécuter sur un
sur un système d'exploitation démarré en
fait ça s'appelle un bout de kits c'est
à dire que ça s'exécute juste avant le
système d'exploitation est un gros ça va
au moment le système d'exploitation est
copié en mémoire vive au tout début en
fait
eh ben ça va exécuter des choses dessus
de sorte que moi quand je me connecte
tout simplement
le mot de passe n'a plus d'importance il
est de toute façon valide
on peut voir le petit chargement il est
en train de charger windows et voilà à
partir de ce moment là c'est fait j'ai
dit à l'heure qu'il suffisait d'une
chaîne vide on va voir si ça marche
voilà c'est en train de s
ouf et donc à chaque fois quand il se
met en veille au fait ça fonctionne
toujours
il n'y a plus la clé moi je retiens
laquelle il avait pas la clé tout à
l'heure ouais tout à l'heure il n'y
avait pas qu'il est donc voilà la clé
elle est juste là au démarrage
en fait ce qui est le plus hallucinant
avec ce truc c'est que ça se fait en
mémoire vive c'est à dire que le à
partir du moment où j'aurai dès mardi y
a plus aucune trace de mon passage en
fait en tout cas il y aura pas trace que
toi tu seras pas exactement j'ai le
temps de faire plein de choses en fait
et toi tu le sauras le jeune tim fait
peur mais qui gérait jamais aux
toilettes quand t'es chez moi je suis
trop peur de te laisser 30 secondes
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
protéger mon ordi qui reste toujours en
veille alors malheureusement il n'y a
pas beaucoup de solutions
la part de la meilleure note
enfin il de base de façon il faut être
prudent mais mais une solution ce serait
deux chiffres est entièrement le disque
dur en fait alors tu as des logiciels
qui sont qui sont faits pour ça et
maintenant c'est vraiment pas très
compliqué à faire si mon disque dur et
chiffré que toi tu arrive chez moi avec
ta petite clé je ne peux rien et que tu
mets dedans ça va être quoi la
différence par rapport à l'acte tout de
suite la différence c'est qu'il va pas
être capables à tout de suite
actuellement
la clé est capable de modifier le code
2d mage est capable de faire l'opération
qui me permets moi d'avoir sa tôt lundi
elle n'a tout simplement rien pouvoir
faire oui ça parlera pas la même langue
mais voilà c'est un peu comme si c'était
de leurs différents pas d'accord donc
chiffrer vos disques durs chiffrés les
chiffres et les mois je vais mettre un
boulier à côté du mien au tout départ
cette vidéo de la faire sur ta chaîne
qui m'a proposé de la faire sur ta
chaine exactement et moi je me suis mais
c'est tellement cool que on pourrait
très bien le faire sur la mienne et ça
vous permet de rencontrer michael et
vous souvenez j'ai eu au mois de
décembre à mix'n qui avait dit fait un
raid sur la chaîne de fabien et vous
êtes arrivé là bas si vous voulez fait
un raid sur la chaîne de michael parce
que toutes les vidéos qui sort elles me
font halluciner
moi j'avais vu la toute première c'est
quand tu à quai les mecs du bon coin
enfin les les arnaqueurs zehnacker des
bonbons shorts arnaquer mais oui mais ça
c'était comme d'habitude si ça vous a
plu mais t'es vraiment un pouce en l'air
je crois que sa salle mairie vous pouvez
également vous abonner à ma chaîne à
celle de michael foncer dessus et on se
donne rendez vous samedi matin à 11h
ouais j'ai décidé ce sera samedi à monza
la prochaine ciao
[Musique]